so this was my first like true
introduction to Lucha Libre and I love
when I get to learn something when I'm
watching a movie I'm I'm curious in your
preparation for the role was there
anything that you learned that has
really stuck with you yeah oh many
things many things I mean fortunately
with all characters there's
always there's always whole complexity
of learning um you know of of um of
experiences that uh that you learn
immediately and also some things that
you learn in the long run no that uh
afterwards in retrospective you go like
ah okay this one this one kind of you
know help me this or that or and uh and
I mean starting from the obvious I guess
you know it gave me the chance to play
with Lucha Li of course you know which
is a game it's a sport that I I mean I
used to play as a game of course when I
was a kid now I used to follow Lucha Li
a lot and um and so it was fun to to
play those characters you know and to
kind of like you know play in the ring
and to learn also the tricks that I that
I never knew how they did it you know
like certain things like uh you know
with the ropes and learning how to fall
and all those kind of things you know um
so and those are very good skills to to
know in life you know knowing how to
fall especially it's it's a very good
one um and then there were other things
that are more much more uh you know
perhaps a bit more abstract and a bit
more uh from a vivid experience you know
of of uh of the of of Lucha Li as well
which are like um you know the
performative aspect it's a sport that
you have to perform a lot no and so in
order to to you have to always never
forget about that and in a way I think
all sports should always have that kind
of quality as well because because most
sports it's only about winning no and uh
and they forget about giving a good show
and uh giving a good show is is a is a
quality that that I think um Hypes the
the performance you know makes you
better and uh and also at the same time
there is a I don't know there is an
immediate satisfaction like that's
that's what they mean when when they say
you know it's not important to win it's
important to compete no
I think that's I mean there's this
comedian that says uh it's not
only about um winning is not only about
competing it's about making the other
one
lose that is very
true that's
obviously that doesn't take
you yeah I mean politicians actually
might might go a long way with that yeah
something you mentioned there was
talking about like the physicality of
this role and it is a very physical role
you're in the ring you're getting tossed
around how much of that was you and how
much of that was like a stunt performer
because it it seems like a lot of it is
you getting thrown around of course of
course well a lot of me was was me and
then and and and the stunt I mean I
worked with a with um in the film with a
stunt team that uh I've been working on
since a long long time ago you know
since Amor peros and that was what was
nice about this family that uh sorry
about this movie is that we did it with
a film with our film family everyone in
the set I had worked with several times
already and uh and so we know each other
we know what's happening we know what
you know like how to take care of each
other and um and so so this stunt team
were incredible because they they were
able to be the interlocutors between the
wrestling world the Lucha Libra world
and the film because uh we went to uh we
work together with a tria which is one
of the biggest organizations of Lucha
Libra in the world and and they were
they were really kind you know they were
really generous and very very very
supportive it was chesman chesman and
Tano Jr my my tutors of this you know of
Lucha and uh and and so you know they
were the stun team was the one kind of
like put things together you know they
they they coordinate that and they they
were at the beginning when I saw it I
was like it's impossible that I'm going
to be able to do that and they were like
no you can you can do that I'm sure I'm
sure you can do that so we trained we
trained and I ended up doing most of
most of the tricks except a couple that
you can actually tell which ones they
are because they are really really
dangerous and those ones I I you know I
maybe in the in the frenetic sort of
hubis I you know I would have like St up
and stood up and said yeah I'm going to
go for it but that's how that's how
careers are ended so did you take any of
the skills that you learned here into
your series your boxing series Lina into
my life no into
my noina no because it's boxing and it's
a whole thing oh yes it's so so
different and boxing I had done before
quite a lot and it's a very different
it's completely different I mean it's a
um yeah
I mean it's absolutely very very
different but there is a little
familiarity in the ring you know of
being in the ring that uh that helped me
I guess to to stand in the ring and be
able to maybe you know what actually
talking you know
the thinking about it
maybe the the wrestling training is so
hard you know it's so
so it hurts so much boxing training also
hurts but there is something more
dangerous with boxing all the time there
is danger all the time and with uh
wrestling there is a way that you can
actually do things and actually you know
hit yourself and stuff but it's not
dangerous it it's hurt it's it's going
to hurt but it's not going to be bad you
know so maybe it did it did help me kind
of like prepare for for you know to to
sustain the you know the pain eventually
I mean but it's a it's a whole different
thing as well like shooting a film
because man the hours it just takes
forever you know and you have to do and
over again and that's something that
even the wrestlers were very tired I can
imagine uh going back to cassandro in
addition to starring you're also an
executive producer on it and I'm curious
for you what was the the process like
the experience like ensuring that this
film was seen by the widest audience
possible well I I think that the the I
mean what we wanted to to hit it on was
especially Lucha lib and uh amazing
story of Cassandra no of of Saul and uh
and those two elements already combined
with a little bit of uh of uh makeup you
know it's it's fantastic in order to to
H to find I don't know for for many
people to find it appealing from the
beginning H definitely knowing Lucha Li
is is is something that kind of helps
but also for the people that don't know
it I mean it's so it might seem from far
away you know very kind of like an
exotic kind of thing you know and stuff
but uh but it's very easy to get into it
and it's very it Sparks a curiosity you
know from the beginning and then I guess
just the participation of everyone in
the film like everyone that started to
to come together you know and we started
to that's the thing that like yes you
want them I mean I want the film to be
seen a lot but mainly first I want the I
mean first I'm foremost I want it to be
a good movie know and uh and that's the
most important thing so so it's
a you know it's starting from there and
then yeah sometimes having a little eye
of like okay let's do this let's do that
but unfortunately I mean in in the
strike uh the film came out so it was
very complicated to to H to sort of
nurture it the with all its might you
know yes the strike was very difficult
I'm also in Sag after and that was a
very difficult couple of months for uh
the film industry um I'm curious you
know I watch a lot of smaller films that
aren't necessarily like the big budget
Blockbusters that everyone's talking
about and I know you have produced a lot
of films over the years and I'm curious
what do you help changes in the industry
to kind of help ensure that these films
have like as much success as possible ah
well that's a yeah that's the question
everyone's asks themselves and then and
between whenever we get a chance to uh
to talk about it and actually that's the
thing that we need to get more chances
to talk about it and to share the
experiences as well
because um you know it's everything has
changed so much so quickly and it's
changing
rapidly there was a a moment where you
know it was natural that there was like
okay this there was the films came out
in cinemas and then they came out uh in
whatever other format but it was like uh
like after the cinemas no and then they
started to go straight into into the
platforms and stuff and so it was um
it lost the chance to uh to sort of you
know it's like in sports when they do
like um you know like a a league that
that is that restricts players from
playing in other areas you know or what
you know those kind of like sponsorship
weird sort of restrictions you know and
and I don't know stupid things really
you know films and so all of a sudden I
mean what having to see the films only
in one platform you know it kind of
loses a a sense of um mystery in many
ways and and uh and I'm not saying it's
it's I mean I'm saying I'm not saying
diminishing the experience of watching
it there but it just but but it just
loses the kind of like a like a natural
pathway as well for for the film to grow
and to have a conversation and to open
up certain things and and I must say
that for me I don't know for many people
maybe some people are more disciplined
than that am when I watch films um
online there is a there is always
something that can distract me always
something that can that I that can take
me away from the film and what I love
about going to the cinema is that uh
you're there and that's it like it's
it's there you know you're in this in
this room you're escaping a little bit
you know also and um and in a way
there's very few things that can
distract you and distract you in a I
mean maybe somebody that's eating
popcorn right beside you you know a lot
you know you know maybe that's
distracting but at the same time it's it
FS the in the nature of watching a film
no sometimes in in when watching online
you know you can hear like um in Mexico
in my where I live in Mexico City like
you can hear some Street vendors outside
and I would like listen to their
dialogue instead of watching the film
and I would get distracted you know so
it's like oh man you know so anyways I'm
I'm just mentioning that that detail
because that as as um intimate as that
can be I think that that is where the
ramifications of how to you know what we
would like the films to to to do you
know like I would love the films to have
all the worlds possible H in order for
them to be able to be seen and to be
enjoyed by by many people that that
actually like to go to the cinema you
know so yeah that's what's beautiful
about the the cinemao experience is it's
communal you're sharing a moment that
can't be replicated anywhere else with
all of these strangers watching the same
film at the same time and there's
something innately beautiful about that
yeah it's super nice but but it's
important not to say that that's the
only way that you can watch films
because you can watch films any way you
want but uh but but it really is like
okay that that's a very heightened
experience you definitely as we wrap up
I did want to talk about one of your
other upcoming projects um I'm a big fan
of your work and I'm also a big fan of
like Diego Luna's career as well so
imagine my surprise last week when that
news dropped about the boys Mexico very
excited for that um how excited are you
about bringing that absolutely insane
franchise to Mexico okay I'm I'm very
excited also but at the same time I'm
excited that because I can because I
cannot talk about it so I know many
Secrets I know many secrets that many
people don't
know um I'm I'm assuming you're a fan of
the series are there any characters from
the boy series that you're like oh God
that's like my I would love to play
something like that are you a fan of
that I can't say anything you can't even
say okay it is fun I had to try exactly
but I am very excited that was kind of
like the biggest news um for me as a fan
of all all three elements of it um so
very excited that well thank you very
much gule this was great I very much
enjoy talking with you and I hope
everybody sees cassandro yes hopefully
yes thank you so much excellent thank
you